foreign
[Music]
how are you you have questions yes I I
had a lot of questions I'm sure you had
a lot of questions but rest assured
we're going to answer them right now
like for example how is Wolverine alive
yeah after Logan Logan uh takes place in
2029 totally separate thing Logan died
in Logan not touching that
what actually happens in our film is
[Music]
jitterbug
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Kevin feige Love You Kevin
feige thank you MCU wake me up
[Music]
hey everyone uh we're extremely sad to
have missed d23 but we've been working
very hard on the next Deadpool film for
uh a good long while now I've had to
really search my soul on this one uh his
first appearance in the MCU obviously
needs to feel special we need to stay
true to the character uh find new depth
and motivation and meaning every
Deadpool needs to stand out and stand
apart it's been an incredible challenge
that has forced me to reach down deep
inside and I
have nothing
yeah
just completely
empty up here
and terrifying but we did have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one
more time
yeah sure
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]